this was a very difficult season for you
he has many other women but you had some
unique challenges this year yeah looking
back what are you most proud of is there
a scene or a moment that sticks out too
well you know I think just overall as a
whole I'm very proud that
um you know that I I managed to continue
to film and show up every single day
despite what I was going through and I
think on some level it was probably the
best thing I could have done you know
when you White Knuckle something you
stay very focused
um of course watching it back you know
it definitely was very triggering and
um you know intense therapy and learning
to live with PTSD and how to navigate it
and you know I guess I'm proud that you
know I'm very grateful I got very lucky
despite what happened I got very lucky
so
um I'm grateful for that it was
incredible to watch your strength you
could see it
um this is a tough reunion it's an
intense reunion what do you obviously
there's not we've talked to you know the
other Housewives a big resolution
doesn't come at the end of it but going
what do you hope it could have ended
like what do you hope could have
happened from that I I I hope that we
I wish that we were all able to have a
cast photo at the end that's what I wish
and unfortunately we didn't
um in a lot of the situations yeah and a
lot of the situations
um you were almost in the middle of
other people's arguments and it felt
like you were being kind of torn apart
how did that weigh on you this season
always weighs on you you know
um I don't like it I don't like but at
the end of the day you know you're you
are navigating friendships you know and
you put eight strong successful you know
independent smart women together and
there's going to be difference of
opinions and conflict and navigating
those friendships so you know I I'm I'm
an optimist and I believe that people
can just mend their uh their conflict
and and you know move on